well i used to go to the comedy cellar  in 92 94.  and uh are you 50. you're 75 years old  yeah so dude when he said his parents  have been a 55 and older community  almost blew my sack off because i'm i am  nine years away from being allowed in  that yeah oh you're nine years away wow  you know what you're saying i'm gonna be  46 43 yeah so yeah we're knocking on  that yeah imagine the day i could do it  dude i would live in an old person's  home in a heartbeat i think it seems so  awesome and you're with your people  packaged you get they get your food you  don't worry about it we're talking to  people nursing home i mean i would want  a little bit nicer five-year-old no  you're not talking about that  you could yeah me into no no my